les pays occidentaux paquin tri gate of
remote et de bernie sanders ce sont les
grands gagnants du super mardi c'est un
rebond impressionnant pour joe biden qui
a remporté 10 état hier soir d'un texas
ce qui lui donne une avance dans le
nombre de délégués de nice 1-2 a gagné
quatre étapes dont la californie l'état
quand même qui rapporte le plus de
délégués michael bloomberg a annoncé ce
matin qu'ils se retiraient de la course
après des résultats désastreux il appuie
maintenant joe biden wall street préfère
la réélection de donald trump mais joe
biden est vue comme états devront
marcher avec nous ce soir
analyse des plates formes économiques
des deux grands candidats qui restent en
quelque sorte même si madame roy rennes
est toujours là mais elle est très très
bas dans le classement
bonsoir julien tourreille on changera
vous êtes chercheur à la chaire raoul
dandurand l'observatoire sur les
états-unis si on place les deux
principaux candidats sur l'échiquier
politique là comment vous les placez
bernie sanders en commençant par lui
c'est le plus facile il se définit comme
un socialiste
donc on le place assez à gauche sur
l'échiquier politique américaine bien
qu'il fallait apporter une nuance au
terme socialisme de la façon dont il
entend ça ressemble plus à de la social
démocratie telle qu'on la connaît dans
les pays scandinaves les sites souvent
le danemark ou telle qu'on la pratique
au canada notamment en termes de système
de santé notamment en termes d'accès à
l'éducation supérieure bien que bernie
sanders ne cite jamais le canada comme
exemple pour ce qui est de joe biden
on a affaire à un centriste alors centre
gauche
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on l'a
vu hier dans son discours de victoire il
tend un petit peu a gauchisé son
discours notamment en envoyant des
petites piques à wall street comme il
l'a fait donc au début de son allocution
d'hier et en expliquant que ce n'est pas
au wall street car bâti la prospérité
des états unis mais la classe moyenne
dont il se positionne comme le champion
de la pour la défendre
alors allons-y avec les propositions
justement de
dubai donne pas beaucoup de chiffres
dans ces mesures jusqu'à maintenant ils
proposent un plan pour la transition
énergétique là dessus il a mis un chip
mais 700 milliards de dollars
oui c'est une obligation si on pu dire
dans le contexte évidemment de
préoccupation mondiale mais même aux
états unis de lutte contre les
changements climatiques
alors c'est pas aussi ambitieux que
certains démocrates de l'ale gauche tels
que bernie sanders
elmer et le faire avec leur fameux green
new deal mais il signale ainsi sa
volonté de prendre à bras le corps ce
problème et d'en profiter aussi pour
créer des opportunités économiques de
relance de création de bons emplois et à
ce titre il se situe très clairement
dans la lignée de ce qu'avait commencé à
faire le président dont il était le vice
président barack obama au cours de ses
huit années à la maison blanche donc
reviendrait quelque part à ce qu'on
connaissait aux états unis avant 2016
l'arrivée de donald trump
il parle de taxer les plus riches donc
abolir les baisses d'impôts du président
entre hommes un taux de 39 6% également
qui est à 20 en ce moment sur les gains
en capital pour les contribuables plus
d'un million de dollars par année
exactement ça ça fait partie aussi du
discours quasiment obligatoire en un
candidat démocrate en campagne pour
obtenir l'investiture de son parti on y
voit là aussi une façon de répondre au
défi quand même que représente bernis
enders alors un petit peu plus la gauche
dans le discours ce qui est aussi
intéressant en matière fiscale c'est
qu'il veut revenir sur les baisses
d'impôts consenties aux grandes
entreprises
on a passé le taux d'imposition de 35 à
21 % en 2017 avec les républicains
majoritaires au congrès et sous
l'initiative évidemment du président
donald trump
joe biden parle on aimerait rehausser
son taux d'imposition des grandes
entreprises alors peut-être pas
nécessairement le remettre à 35 % parce
qu'il en va de la compétitivité des
entreprises américaines notamment à
l'amérique du nord ou notamment face à
leurs rivales européennes il est tout à
fait ouvert à cette idée d'augmenter les
impôts des grandes entreprises et des
américains est prenante en matière de
santé il parle d'étendre l'obamacare une
option d'assurance médicale publique et
la fin des exemptions de taxes pour les
publicités pharmaceutiques
oui hélas ils estiment en fait qu'il
faut poursuivre le travail initié par
obama avec la réforme adoptée en 2010
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
c'est la solution la plus raisonnable
d'un point de vue de coût budgétaire ça
permet de limiter l'ampleur de la
réforme le coût de la réforme mais aussi
de limiter la hausse des frais médicaux
aux états unis on sait que le système
est particulièrement coûteux même s'il
est efficace d'un point de vue médical
l'autre élément qui prend en
considération en évoquant cette
nécessité d'améliorer obamacare c'est
l'attachement des américains à leur
système de santé tels qu'ils connaissent
notamment grâce à leur entreprise ou
grâce à l'assurance individuelle même
s'ils proposent pour ceux qui n'ont pas
une option publique
bernie sanders en tout cas lui propose
une assurance santé universel un green
new deal la gratuité scolaire
l'annulation des dettes étudiantes la
garderie universel et préscolaire
l'accès aux lieux où le juin ce sont des
réformes très importantes qu'il a
chiffré les chiffres que vous voyez à
droite l'a 47 mille milliards par
exemple c'est sur dix ans oui et pour
donner une illustration de l'ampleur de
la réforme qui propose la révolution qui
propose comme ils le diraient lumens 47
mille milliards de dollars sur dix ans
quand même à mettre en relation avec le
budget de l'état fédéral qui à l'heure
actuelle de 4.7 milliards par année donc
ça donne une idée de du changement
profond 1 milliards 7,7 par année mais
ils sont 47 milliards c'est sur dix ans
exactement mais ça pose le problème du
financement de cette réforme là alors
lui il estime qu'en augmentant
significativement les impôts sur les
plus riches sur les grandes entreprises
ça permettra de
de le financer et une étude qu'il aime
beaucoup cité ces derniers temps de
l'université il lui donne en partie
raison en disant que c'est vrai que en
augmentant la cise fiscale on pourrait
financer mais qu en partie ce type de
réforme là il y aurait quand même un
manque à gagner et ce manque à gagner
serait comblé en partie par une
augmentation des impôts sur les classes
moyennes
ce que m'ont pas évidemment 1-2 souligné
joe biden absolument il faut dire que
les américains doivent payer pour des
assurances privées espérées pour des
assurances publiques via leurs impôts en
quelque sorte
exactement et donc est par ailleurs
bunny 102 et contre la séoune l'accord
de libre échange canada etats unis
mexique
oui il est contre les accords de libre
échange en général alors historiquement
il a toujours été contre ces accords là
il était contre l'alena par exemple
parce qu'ils estiment non seulement
qu'ils ont des coûts environnementaux
significatifs et là aussi c'est une
préoccupation en partie de l'électorat
le plus jeune qui soutient bernie
sanders et il estime aussi qu'il ya des
coûts pour les américains qui ont perdu
de bons emplois industriels il a encore
rappelé hier soir alors il est contre
l'accord canada etats unis mexique
il est contre aussi un éventuel retour
des etats unis dans le fameux
partenariat transpacifique avec a changé
de nom depuis que les onze partenaires à
après que les états-unis soient retirés
sous donald 30 ans ont signé en mars
2018 alors que joe biden lui estime que
les accords de libre échange sont un peu
du gagnant gagnant et que peut-être dans
le cas de l'accord un trans pacifique il
serait bon que les états unis sous sa
présidence
je cherche à leurs intérêts julien
tourreille merci beaucoup pour cette
analyse ce soir merci merci beaucoup